[Musique]
alors ils ont un problème hmm le
noir est noir hmm Je n'ai aucune preuve Je
sais que la vie est dure comme du bois parfois mais
je promets que je serai là pour que tu
ne vois toujours pas Je suis né dans la rue J'ai dû
me battre
Oh Mary  si vous saviez seulement la douleur que j'ai
dû traverser et maintenant le temps fuit
mais tous les temps le
rock and roll est fini c'est génial
c'est fini
rappelez-vous que je vous ai parlé de mon pote Diego
Diego libre dans sa tête un jour viendra
et toi '  Je serai plus comme eux, je suppose donc
une bonne chose est que je refuse de mourir
en prison, nous avons tous une certaine location à l'intérieur
de nous et n'oublions jamais que
je dois avoir l'attitude rock and roll est-ce que
j'arrête c'est à l'heure du coucher que
les portes du pénitencier se fermeront  bientôt
[Musique]
vous